Courtney Cox's daughter KOCO interviews
her famous mama and it's just about the
cutest thing ever
I'm extremely thankful I feel very
blessed to have Coco in a new clip for
Courtney's Facebook watch series 9
months with Courtney Cox the actress is
15 year old daughter with ex David
Arquette got over her nerves and
peppered her mom with questions during
your pregnancy journey with me wait whoa
their favorite food while pregnant I
used to love Coco even snuck in a
friend's question tell me the first word
you associate with when Coco asked what
she was like as a young child Courtney
got a little too cheesy for the now
teenager absolutely adorable curious
incredible sense of humor important
you're annoying haha et spoke to Coco's
dad david arquette in April where he got
just as Moshe over there talented young
daughter Coco's at that age were like
her parents are not the coolest like
she's a teenager mom and dad I'm busy
kind of a thing yeah definitely not the
coolest but all things considered she's
a really great person that's sort of oh
by the way a really great person with an
unbelievable singing voice Kourtney's
put some of those videos
what a talent she is he's incredible
she's got more talent than I ever had or
ever could and confidence which is
really amazing
[Music]